Yeah.
And we're live,
ladies and gentlemen,
Lance Armstrong.
How are you buddy?
Good man.
Thanks.
Thanks for doing this.
Appreciate it.
Thanks for having me.
I really appreciate it.
For your frill.
And,
um,
you know,
you were just telling me before this,
uh,
we were talking about social media and
social media.
The greatest part about social media as
he get in contact with everybody,
the worst part about social media is
that you get in contact with everybody.
And it was just this tiny percentage of
people that won't let it rest.
Like I was looking at something that you
posted and uh,
it was something about some,
like you had a great time doing some
race and like one of the first tweets,
one of the first comments was,
uh,
yeah,
as good at times running away from drug
toasts are,
yeah,
that's right.
You're,
you're just going to have,
what did we,
I'm at posted the other day.
We were,
we were,
we were putting our Christmas tree up
and my family,
you know,
they all the kids there and Anna and the
lights and the,
and the ornaments and it's at the
fucking Christmas tree.
And you know,
of course most people love it.
They think it's a cute picture.
But then there's always the one,
you know,
the tree is the tree juiced or,
or something.
I mean,
there's just always,
which I get,
I mean that's just part of it,
but sometimes you're like,
is that the best we got?
Like,
yeah.
I mean maybe that is,
maybe I deserved,
I dunno.
But it's like give it a rest sometimes.
Well,
you definitely deserve some of it,
right?
Yeah,
for sure.
There's no way around of course this,
but it's also,
I think one of the things about this
whole scandal,
the whole thing,
it illuminated the real issue and the
real issue is the entire,
and this is what we're talking about.
Bill Byrd did that thing on Conan or he
was saying,
look,
the fucking whole sport is like this.
It's not,
there was all the people that won the
Tour de France and all the years that
you did it.
If you go back to people that either
weren't implicated or didn't test
positive,
like what is it,
like 18th place or something fucking
crazy like that,
you know,
that that's probably generous.
I,
yeah,
right.
It would be,
um,
it would be hard to know,
hard to know that.
And um,
I mean they,
look,
Joe,
these are all easy for me to,
to sit here and say and talk about.
And people would say,
well,
of course he says that.
Right?
Of course he thinks that talks on the
table now you really don't have anything
to get it,
but is it,
it is.
No,
I mean it's,
um,
well I guess it is,
but you know,
people don't want to talk about that.
I mean,
people want to talk about my issue and
that's,
I guess also understandable.
Um,
but like it was a,
it was a fucked up time.
And,
and you had this,
you were at this crossroads of have a
very hard sport,
uh,
I very hard event.
Some would say one of the hardest
sporting events in the world,
three weeks,
2,500 miles,
conditions,
terrain,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So that meets really the perfect drug.
When you have a drug that's,
that's incredibly beneficial and at the
totally undetectable,
um,
and,
and everybody dove in.
And so,
um,
nobody,
nobody wanted to be in that position.
It's not like any of us growing up as
kids thought,
dude,
I'm going to,
I'm going to go to Europe and get all
doped up and tried to went packers.
No,
nobody wanted to be there.
Like,
we all went with pure intentions.
We got there and we're like,
and I'm talking about to this crop of
Americans that went to Europe and the
shit was messy.
And we're like,
whoa.
Like,
okay,
do we go home or do we stay in fight?
And,
uh,
literally,
almost everybody stayed and fought and
they fought.
We fought the way that,
that the fight was being fought.
And um,
you know,
and,
and that all meets with where we are
today.
And the people who were there,
I think can speak to it.
Me and my teammates,
my peers,
my rivals,
the competition.
Um,
and we have a unique perspective on it
because we were,
we were in the war,
but the person on main street,
right,
the corner of main and first wasn't
there and they don't understand it.
And so they can't really speak to it,
but that doesn't change the fact that
they're disappointed.
They're,
they're really disappointed.
That disappointed me,
that disappointing the sport.
Uh,
they might hate me,
they might hate the sport.
Um,
then they were most likely defenders of
mine.
And so they're pissed off.
And I,
you know,
it's taken me a long time to really
understand that.
Um,
but I'll spend the rest of my life
trying to,
trying to work that one out with that
person.
And I,
and I don't,
you know,
they're out there,
they're millions of them,
so,
um,
well they have a legitimate point.
But there's also,
there's people out there that want you
to be wrong and want you,
they want to find someone who's done
something bad and never let it go.
And I think there's,
there's definitely some of that going
on.
And there's also people that they don't
have a lot of sympathy for people who've
been extremely successful.
And I've made mistakes.
Like it gives them the green light to
just decide to just continually attack
you.
But if I,
when I tried to do,
when this whole thing was going down,
as I tried to put myself in your
position,
like you're this worldclass biker,
it's 1994 and that's right around when
you started using [inaudible] 95 95.
So around this time,
when you realize what those 20 years
ago,
20 years ago,
it's kind of crazy,
right?
When you realize that this,
that pretty much all the best guys,
we're doing this now.
What is that feeling like when you're
like,
okay,
I've got a crossover into this deceptive
territory.
Now all of a sudden I'm,
uh,
I have to lie about this.
I have to hide this and have to be a
part of this sort of underground thing,
this underground aspect that's a part of
great sport,
right?
Well,
W we,
we held off as long as you know,
I mean,
uh,
you know,
epl came along in the early nineties.
Um,
we SORTA got to Europe in [inaudible] 92
93.
Um,
and then it,
it by that point,
by nine fords,
you know,
full on and we're thinking,
okay,
this isn't good,
but surely they're going to have a test
for this free flow.
Um,
and we waited,
we waited and it just never came.
And then,
uh,
then we get to 95.
There's tremendous pressure on the team
within the team.
Uh,
we're losing the sponsor.
Will the sponsor renew?
The team wants results and we're going,
all right,
we're,
we're really fucked here.
And so we all collectively made the
decision in spring of [inaudible] 95
that,
all right,
we have to go play ball the first time
you shot that stuff.
What was that like?
That it's not,
it's,
it's not like a,
I knew you were going to ask these
questions.
It's not like that.
It's not that type of drug.
It's not like,
no,
I don't mean like cocaine or,
or it's not,
it's not,
I didn't mean it that way.
I met was there a feeling like,
God,
fuck,
we've crossed into this land of
cheating.
It was so long ago and that would have
been,
that was 21 years ago or 20 years ago.
It's a little tough to remember exactly.
Um,
um,
you know,
it also too,
I mean it wasn't as if there were other
things we did before that,
I mean their eco is,
is this hugely powerful drug.
But,
but there was,
you know,
we sort of,
uh,
call them gateway drugs.
I mean,
if,
if people is,
you know,
is,
is the myth of performance enhancing
drugs.
I mean there's,
there's marijuana too.
There's,
there's a lighter sort of entry level
stuff that,
what was the entry,
what was the first time cortisone?
Is,
is there another is to relieve pain or
just,
uh,
yeah,
I mean it is,
but it also works for,
for racing bikes.
But how does it work for racing bikes?
Um,
well,
it's such a strong anti-inflammatory
that you,
with that you just inevitably,
you feel better.
Whether it's physically you feel better,
a certain,
even just a euphoria that comes with
that.
That's,
you know,
and who knows what,
percent of it,
but at the same time you have,
you have a drug that,
um,
you know,
I love it when you,
when you know,
in cycling,
if you took cortisone,
you,
you would be,
it would be banned.
However you under your watch,
you know,
the NFL and then somebody gets,
gets banged up in the first half.
They go in at halftime,
they come out,
you know,
the announcer says they went in and they
got it.
They got a cortisone injection.
There'll be,
they're going to play the second half.
They rest for a hundred yards.
They win the game,
their hero.
It's like,
wait a second.
Yeah.
Like,
so it is what it is,
but it is weird.
It's weird what we've
talked about that a bunch of times.
Me and my friends,
like when you go to Gnc or you know,
like the UFC has this company,
uh,
muscle farm which sells a bunch of
supplements and things along those
lines,
but yet they ban performance enhancing
drugs.
Like,
well what are these supplements do?
Well,
they enhance you some way,
like a certain level.
Well we'll allow,
allow a certain level of improvement,
certain level of aid in recovery.
But anything past that as cheating,
well it's all performance.
A nap,
his performance in his short vitamins.
So we know that.
Right?
But,
but they're also a two has to be,
and I don't want to be critical of
whether it's the UFC is efforts to,
to combat doping or are you sought or
water or the anybody or any major sport.
You have to draw the line somewhere.
That's just,
and I get asked that all the time
because people,
people get frustrated with the issue and
it's,
they kind of throw their hands up and
said,
well look,
we should just,
it should just all be legal.
And,
you know,
they said that to me and they're,
they're thinking I'm going to go,
yeah,
you're right.
But you can't,
that's not the answer either.
There has to be a structure in place.
There has to be aligned.
And it might,
that line might seem weird or fuzzy to
people sometimes,
but shit,
you have to have something.
Um,
and so
dude,
it's tricky.
I mean,
anytime you mix,
uh,
athletes that are,
that are super motivated with,
um,
with money,
with a pressure that comes with that
temptation that comes with that.
You know,
people are for the rest of,
I mean,
come on.
the original Olympic Games they were,
there were there was going on.
So it's,
you have to think that it's going to
happen forever.
It,
the substances will change over time.
But,
um,
it just,
unfortunately,
it's part of the game.
So the original writers like way back in
the early days of the Tour de France,
before they had drugs,
they were using alcohol.
You know,
there's all the,
there's a lot of stories about,
um,
whether it's alcohol,
cocaine,
um,
and crazy substances.
But,
but at the same time you had guys,
the Tour de France is a hundred years
old,
right?
So,
uh,
doping is cheating.
We know that.
But there's other ways.
I mean,
guys would hang on to cars,
guys would get in trains.
They were guys,
they would take a cork out of,
out of a wine bottle and they would put
this is this fucking crazy?
They would have fishing string in the
cork,
right?
So wired up and they would have it,
you know,
they have a car off the road and they'd
put it in the neuro cheat.
Oh my.
And you know,
just a subtle pole.
I mean,
did they,
you know,
any way to get ahead?
I mean,
this is,
you know,
the,
um,
the sport is just that it's a brutal
sport and you're not getting your face
pounded in like ufc,
but you certainly feel like you're
getting your face pounded.
Well,
psychologically it's almost more
devastating cause it's so grinding when
you're talking about something that
three weeks and he goes,
is it 2100 2,500 miles?
Is that what it is?
2,500.
That's insane.
That's an insane amount of time pushing
your body
a hundred miles a day.
But once you get to the top level,
it's remarkable how efficient it is.
I mean,
you have 200 guys going down the road on
a normal day.
If it's a flat day and there's not wind
or crosswind,
um,
or rain or you know,
the conditions,
it's pretty easy to be honest.
I mean,
it's conversational.
The final is tough on the final gets
fast and people are competing for the
stage went.
But,
um,
it's not,
you know,
those three weeks aren't like three
weeks on the law.
I mean,
on,
you know,
in the red line.
So you have to pace yourself.
The peloton paces itself,
like the,
you know,
they sort of pace and police for,
for lack of a better word itself.
And when,
you know,
obviously the mountains and the time
trials or where the race is decided and
those are the hardest moments
when they first started introducing,
uh,
things like,
um,
uh,
when I started using the transfusions
and things along those lines,
how much of an improvement did it have
on the times?
Well,
you know,
it's,
it's hard to say because the Times that,
you know,
people look at our era,
they look at my generation and they say,
okay,
well the time supposed to be,
you know,
significantly faster and be immediately,
but you can't compare cycling to track
and field or cycling to another sport
that's had had a rough patch and is now
trying to clean itself up because
technology changes,
road surfaces change.
Obviously training has changed.
But um,
I mean if you go back to the 84 games
right here in Los Angeles,
that was really the first major exposure
you had for,
for transfusions,
um,
which,
which the American team did in rolling
stone exposed it.
Um,
but uh,
transfusion is just a,
it was an old school hipo replace that,
right?
Because you had a transfusion is just
adding red sales to your system,
which carries oxygen and,
and gives you more oxygen.
Then you had a drug came along that did
that for you.
So you didn't have to extract the blood.
You didn't have to put it back in.
It made it,
you know,
it made it a lot easier.
And then when the test,
when they refined the protest and
ultimately came up with it,
um,
uh,
then people went back to the old school
system.
So,
um,
and then came other ways to detect that
through not so much through a test,
but just through what they call the
biological passport.
So just studying parameters and your
blood,
whether it's ridiculous sites or red
cells or you know,
all of these things that the smart
people can come up with tests for.
That's,
it was more of a screening method to
detect,
uh,
a transfusion.
What's Kinda fucked up about all this is
that
you won the Tour de France seven times.
You obviously trained like a demon,
pushed yourself to the limits.
You beat everyone in the competition and
they were all doing the same thing you
were doing right.
Yet you're the one who was demonized and
yet you're the one who takes all the
grief.
Yup.
Yeah.
And
there's a situation that happens when
you're involved.
You're involving money,
you're involving sponsors,
you're involved.
When you,
once you first start,
once the ball starts rolling and the
first deception has been launched out
there into the ether.
Yup.
There's no way to take it back if you
want to keep racing.
Yup.
Yep.
And that's the thing.
I mean people look,
I mean my situ,
my story and,
and I,
I hear you loud and clear and you can
say that.
I can never say that.
You know,
when I,
if I were to say things like that,
people would,
they would nuke me.
But it is what it is,
what it is.
But that's anyhow,
um,
there was the doping,
okay.
Which led to the lying.
Right.
Which led to the treatment of other
people.
I think by and large,
people can have the perspective that you
have.
They can say,
well,
looks to me like everybody did it.
So,
okay.
Uh,
then they can look to the line and they,
that's where they really start to not
like it.
I said,
this guy lied to us repeatedly,
but of course you get,
you know,
my,
there's no defense to that.
But if I could,
if I could share any personal insight.
I mean,
once you lie,
once you just keep lying to keep lines.
Not as if I'm going to sit here,
you know,
this is 15 years ago and Joe,
you're a nice guy and you,
I mean,
if I was on this podcast,
I would lied to your fucking face a
million times.
Just so you know,
I would've just shown you now,
just so you know.
But that's not a surprise to you or
anybody else,
but,
but once you're in there,
it's not as if I'm going to go,
you know,
this,
this guy joe seems like a really nice
guy.
I think I'm going to be real.
I'm gonna be honest with him.
Too much money.
There's no way you can't once that.
Yeah.
So I was,
I was stuck,
for lack of a better word in that,
uh,
in that,
does that lie or that deception?
But then the way that I took my
competitive nature,
which served me well in training and in
racing,
and took it into the real world,
took it into a press conference,
took it into a personal relationship,
took it into former teammates.
Uh,
my relationship with that,
what,
that's the part where people go,
okay,
fuck this guy forever.
Right?
I'm done.
And so,
um,
that,
you know,
you've got sort of the three phases.
None of them are good,
but as it got further away,
um,
that,
you know,
lack of respect for others is the thing
that totally fucked me.
And you know,
too,
that I would,
I would say to anybody that I understand
and,
um,
I may be in their timeout forever.
Um,
I have,
uh,
and the only thing I will add that,
that,
that may sound like I'm trying to defend
myself as I've,
I've tried to make amends with all those
people,
right?
The ones that we all know,
the ones people talk about,
I've traveled the world,
I've sat with them,
I've,
I've looked them in the eyes and said
what I did was totally unacceptable and
I'm sorry.
Um,
and almost everybody has accepted the
apology and,
and,
and we've moved on.
Um,
but that doesn't get to this,
this,
you know,
this crowd of people that,
that you can't sit with face to face and
you can't say you're sorry.
I mean,
I can talk to you,
we can talk about it.
Some people may view that as an apology
or are or not,
but,
but the ones that I could go sit with,
I did.
And that's all that I would add to that.
And I,
and I,
I mean,
I'm proud that most of those people,
and I say most,
not everybody,
because not everybody's ready,
but most of those people said,
you know what?
We're good.
We're done.
And so,
uh,
if it was my son and he acted that way,
first of all,
I'd say,
the fuck are you doing?
You can't act that way.
But I had no,
nobody was standing over me going,
dude,
what?
What are you,
you're acting like an asshole.
Nope.
Nobody did that.
So,
but if my son did that,
I would say you get over there and you
make it right with that person.
So that's where it is.
And uh,
here we go.
You're also in this bizarre position at
the time to be the only famous cycler
and the entire country cyclist cycler
isn't on it.
That's a cycler cycling drugs,
hiker,
biker,
but a bikers like sons of anarchy and
that's,
yeah.
Yeah.
I kind of got burned out on that series.
But
um,
yeah,
I mean the story weight to carry around.
Yeah.
And then there's the cancer
organizations live strong.
All of it has a lot of weight you're
carrying around.
I speak to it all the time.
I mean it was,
it was a huge wave,
but you're also balancing out so much
good with this lie and this lie is
helping.
All is good,
right?
Like the live strong foundation is
generating hundreds of millions of
dollars helping all these people with
cancer.
I've seen you in the hospitals with
these kids and it makes it mean me
having kids myself,
it makes me cry seeing these kids with
face masks on because their immune
system,
so compromise and they don't have any
hair and they're just devastated.
And you're hanging out with these kids
and you,
you're generating all this positive
energy for them,
generating all this money,
all this,
all this research that's being funded.
So there's all this good as well.
You start telling the truth that
stopped.
We know what happens because it
happened.
Yeah.
It did happen.
It happened to,
and we dried up.
I don't see any of those fucking
bracelets anymore.
No,
Goddamn,
things were everywhere.
Yeah.
Yeah,
they were.
We had a good run and 85 million
bracelets.
Yeah.
But look,
I mean,
I don't want anybody to be mistaken.
I,
my interests were selfish.
I mean,
I was,
uh,
um,
defending myself and protecting myself.
Uh,
but at the same time,
it wasn't just myself.
I was protecting,
I was protecting the sport.
I was protecting our sponsors.
I was protecting the tour.
I was protecting the foundation.
Um,
and,
you know,
it's just hard to say I'm going to,
I'm going to stop and,
and,
and what we just said.
I mean,
we now know on all of those things,
right?
We know what's happened to the
foundation.
We know what's happened to the sport,
we know what's happened to the sponsor.
We know,
and we can now see.
Um,
it was,
it was a devastating tall and,
um,
you know,
most would say,
well,
that's all your fault lance.
And,
uh,
and,
and maybe they're right,
but,
uh,
it's,
it's been,
you know,
did it,
especially on the foundations I did,
it just breaks my heart to see that,
um,
the effect it's had on their
effectiveness,
well,
it's got to be way more complicated
then.
It's just your,
all your fault.
It's,
it's,
it's way more complicated because when
you're talking about and tire sport,
that's dirty.
I mean,
for lack of a better word,
an entire sport that's being deceptive
entire sport that's using these
performance enhancing drugs.
And then you're talking about you
because you're this weird outlier here.
This one guy who is incredibly
successful at it in a country where
nobody gave a fuck about the Tour de
France until you came along.
I mean,
he's Greg Lamon you.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean there's,
yeah,
I mean,
that's it.
That's the only,
this is the,
I mean,
the story in the story being what it was
a cancer survivor that comes back that
when's this event the transcends the
sport that brings a sport to psych.
And although greg to do,
I mean a tremendous job really,
that was like the first blow up of
cycling and the United States and then
comes my story.
I mean,
that's,
the story was soap.
The story was too big,
right?
I mean,
and that's the reason that,
that uh,
that incentivized and motivated people
like,
uh,
like Novitsky and like the feds to come
along and say,
oh,
a hundred percent,
hundred percent.
I mean,
they're not,
they're not doing that to save the
world.
They're not doing that to save the
children no matter what.
Ulterior motives that they might,
you know,
try to list as well.
We wanted to make sure the children
don't do this.
We wanted to send a great message.
We have bullshit.
It's,
it's a high profile,
high publicity v Avenue for them to
achieve notoriety.
Yeah.
But,
but,
right.
And we will get into that.
But the,
the,
you know,
my rival,
so if you take,
you know,
my main main,
main rivals,
whether it's young,
old rick or Baso are bulkier been tawny
or their star factor,
for lack of a better phrase,
was just,
was just different.
And they,
you know,
they weren't cancerous wasn't,
so it,
it,
there was this disparity which the sport
enabled there to be because it just kind
of an old school,
Janky sport in terms of the way it's
organized and run as a business.
Um,
that it,
it was like a,
you know,
like a South American economy.
There was really the haves and the have
nots.
And uh,
that's a crazy way of putting it.
Yeah.
I mean,
when,
when you have something like that,
it doesn't work.
And so what you need to,
you know,
all of those ships need to rise with
that.
See.
And,
and,
um,
I probably didn't do a good enough job,
uh,
trying
to push for that in my,
in my time.
Um,
but don't you have only a certain amount
of resources?
I mean,
with,
one of the things that I've always said
about extreme winters is,
uh,
there's,
there's a borderline between greatness
and madness and he crosses back and
forth.
Yeah.
I would say the greatest and madness are
next door neighbors and they borrow each
other's sugar because there's almost no
way you can get that good without almost
losing your fucking mind.
Yeah.
Right.
I haven't met some people that are
fantastic at things,
the great ones.
I've met great ones,
especially great fighters,
and they're all fucking crazy.
Yeah.
It's almost like you can't,
you can't not be because every,
you can't be a regular guy and get
there.
Right.
I probably was.
I probably still am a little crazy.
Oh,
you're crazy.
I couldn't tell you.
Definitely crazy.
No,
but I don't,
I don't think you're bad.
I don't think you're a bad guy.
I mean,
I don't know you that well,
but I,
I just think you have to have that,
that sharpness.
Yeah.
You have to have that,
that grit.
You have to have that aggressive
competitive nature in order to succeed.
Especially in some fucking thing where
everyone's doing the same thing.
There's not a lot of creativity
involved.
There's not a lot of the variables.
You're fucking pushing yourself and the
machine yourself.
You're pumping your legs.
That's it.
You can't,
you know,
can't fake to the left and go to the
ride.
He can't fucking throw up some new moves
that no one's ever seen before.
You're,
you're,
you're fucking wishing yourself.
Yeah.
You definitely had some of those,
but at the end of the day,
you're on a fucking bike and everybody
else is on a bike and you're going up
the Goddamn same hill and there were no
secrets.
Right.
The Dat,
dat concentrates down what the
competitive nature is to like the edge.
Who's got the sharper edge?
Who's more intense and you John,
because of that and,
right.
He's getting riled up.
I get riled up,
dude.
It was,
I'm gonna step back.
Don't,
don't,
don't jump across this table.
I mean,
isn't that a big old Kettlebell over
here?
You should come over here.
Just settle down.
Isn't that what it is?
That it has to be what it is.
It's the only way to win.
It's,
it's an endurance event so you have to
be a little careful with that.
But there are those moments where you
just have to unleash everything you have
and you're going to unleash them in
training or an in racing and yet,
but yes,
that seems like a really good point
where you just put that up is there's,
you have to be careful with that.
You have to know when to put like how
you have to know your body like really
intimately as far as you didn't,
you have to manage it over the course of
many,
many women say the marathon,
I mean nobody takes off and you know,
like it's a hundred yard dash.
I mean you have to manage that.
Obviously you have the experience of
knowing what that effort is going to
look and feel like and you know how to
manage all of that.
But yeah,
I mean three weeks long,
man,
you've gotta be,
you gotta be careful.
Yeah.
Is there a moment where you remember
like during the race where you wanted to
push but you had to back down like there
was,
is there moments where you like you're
managing don't have it,
but yeah.
Where you feel like this is not a smart
thing to go.
Yeah.
And you know,
now you can,
I mean,
when we raised,
you know,
well in the old days people just drained
and they thought,
well,
I'm gonna go hard today and I'm going to
go easy tomorrow.
And then it came the heart rate monitor
and they followed their heart rate and
they met,
you know,
they manage their training or racing
through that and then came the power
meters.
And then so now there's all these,
you know,
there are these devices where you can
really monitor all of that stuff.
And so you're out there,
you're not just sort of driving around
blind.
I mean,
you actually can see what you're doing
and you,
and that makes managing that effort a
lot easier.
What is it,
what are the differences in the numbers?
Like if you go back to like a hundred
years ago,
well,
you assuming that people weren't using
corkscrews and or corks and fishing line
and whatever other ways she didn't.
Yeah.
Like what,
what is like a realistic difference
between the early days of winning and to
just,
it's like a modern site clean.
I mean,
you have to look at when,
when,
you know,
the bike basically got to the,
the bikes and the wheels and these
things got to where they are today.
And,
um,
you know,
they're,
uh,
they're fast now.
I mean,
these guys are fast and that's the,
you know,
two things have happened.
Number One,
my story,
uh,
got exposed.
And so then people question everybody,
whether it's Chris froome who won the
Tour de France this year,
or somebody that wins the world
championships,
they questioned them because of me.
And then they say,
well,
okay,
you know,
he's dirty.
It seems like everybody's dirty,
so you must be dirty.
And then they go to the times,
right?
They look at,
they look at,
uh,
they look at my times in the Tour de
France and they look at the Peloton is
times and they see now that the times
are actually either the same or better.
So I said,
well,
then of course that that supports my
argument that you're dirty,
you know,
how's it?
Well,
if it's fat,
I mean,
I don't know.
I mean it,
it,
I don't have the answer to that.
And I,
and I,
you know,
I get asked all the time what's going on
now or what's,
I said,
I have no idea.
I mean,
I'm so far removed from cycling that I
have no earthly idea of what's going on
or not going on.
But I don't think it's necessarily fair
to blame those guys.
I don't,
I understand it,
but,
um,
you know,
shit,
I mean,
you could have these athletes might be a
lot better.
The training might be a lot better.
I do think technology,
the bikes,
the wheels,
even road surfaces are a lot better.
And
is there a,
is there any part of you that's kind of
pissed off that there are performance
enhancing drugs?
Like if there was nothing and if we just
had to be Mano a Mano,
same result,
you would have the same result.
I would have this,
it is my belief that
that the results would be the same.
There'll be a few seconds slower or
whatever,
whatever it would be.
It doesn't matter if the overall time
slower.
What matters is,
is,
is if you were five minutes ahead of the
next guy,
that's what matters.
That's what matters.
I,
that's my belief.
But there are others that don't hold
that belief.
There are others that say no,
I mean doping effects other individuals
differently.
And you know,
you,
you wouldn't know.
You might have one,
two or you might've went none.
What does that mean is that some people
weren't doping correctly,
but look at once you're doping,
if you're doping and the other guy's
doping better than you,
like,
well then you're not doing your job
doping.
You know,
you're not being a good competitive
doper bill.
But I mean,
that's really what it is,
right?
I mean,
doesn't it make sense?
Uh,
it's,
it gets complicated.
And W we would talk forever and,
and people would argue with us forever
about that.
So
they're not here,
you know,
I mean,
just who they are if you're listening.
But my perspective is,
is really clear on that.
I mean,
I think if you have a sport where
everybody's,
you know,
we were both talking about the bill
birth thing that he did on Conan,
which is like,
yeah,
our psychopath is Beth and you're a
psychopath.
You know?
That's,
that's really what it is.
You,
you can't say that.
I mean,
how could they take away,
this is one of the things that drove me
the craziest about this.
Like what did they do with the seven
years where you one where they said,
you're not the winter anymore.
Well,
who the fuck wanted then that's,
you know,
how do you,
how do you find the guy who wanted show?
That's,
that's,
that's a problem.
What's in the record books.
That's it.
It's empty.
Empty,
empty,
empty for seven years.
Yeah.
That's ridiculous.
Look,
I you you,
I agree with you,
but you can say that I cannot say that.
All I will say is that I don't,
I don't think it's
far be it for me to talk about what's
fair or not fair,
but I don't think it's fair for the
sport to leave those empty.
I think that's crazy.
And,
and compare and contrast.
So when the tour,
you have the Yellow Jersey,
he's the guy who wins.
You have the Polka Dot Jersey is
technically the best climber.
And then you have the Green Jersey who
was technically the best sprinter.
Those seven years were the Green Jersey
was one by Zabul who admitted to having
dope all seven of those years.
The polka Dot Jersey was,
was was one by veranique from France who
admitted to having dumped all those
years,
those all stand,
everything's still there.
That's hilarious.
But the Yellow Jersey has been erased,
you know,
second place,
third place.
All those places are still there.
The years,
the years prior to me where it's
somebody was,
he had admitted or was caught all still
there.
So there's just an asterisk in first
place.
You go to Wikipedia,
it's just there's just a line through
it.
Yeah.
That's so strange.
That's the word,
man.
It's strange.
It's very strange.
And it's strange for me and I it,
and it makes me,
it makes me sad because,
um,
uh,
I'm gonna look,
I'm gonna be honest.
I believe I won the races.
Um,
and I think,
well,
no,
you did win the races.
Now you won the race.
People to ask are the ones that got
beat.
Yeah.
So if you ask them,
right,
if you're asking Keon if you asked to do
a left,
he asked,
uh,
below.
If you ask any of them,
they say he won those bike races.
And so,
man,
it,
you still have those yellow jerseys in
your house and I'd have to give them
back.
No,
good.
Fuck them.
She put it on an instagram picture of
him every day.
That was,
yeah,
that,
yeah.
I'm not going to put that picture up
again,
but that was a great picture though.
Oh,
you chilling on the couch at seven
yellow jerseys on your wall.
I got,
I got a note for that one.
Wow.
You're going to get new no matter what
you do.
But,
but I,
I look,
I mean,
they're up.
They're up and,
uh,
and,
and I'm proud of them.
I really am.
And I'm proud of,
and that's the thing too,
is that as weird as it is,
and as strange as it is,
that there's just a line through those
years as if they did not happen.
Um,
man,
I had,
I was paid to do a job,
right.
As messy as the job was,
whatever.
I was paid to do it.
And I did it.
Uh,
and I wanted to win.
I wanted to capture those memories for
myself and for my teammates.
And you can't,
nobody can take those away from me.
I still hold those memories to myself.
And,
um,
yeah,
it's,
it's had a complicated ending,
but,
um,
you know,
I still view those as victories and I
still view those memories is good.
The caring round,
the lie,
and being interrogated and questioned.
And it was that the hardest part about
all of it,
you know,
I was,
I was only interrogated are questioned
with the press and,
and even,
um,
you know,
God,
if it would have been in this day and
age with,
with,
with twitter and facebook and social
media and,
uh,
it would,
it would have been a thousand times
worse.
I mean,
this was,
you know,
I mean,
this was in the late nineties.
think about that.
That was a long time ago.
And so the level of scrutiny while it
was high wasn't nearly as high as it
would have been today.
Um,
but
yeah,
I mean,
once you dig in,
you know,
with these,
with these guys,
you're,
you're stuck.
So once you finally came clean,
I mean,
obviously there was a lot of blow back,
but was there also a relief?
Um,
not,
not immediately.
Not immediately.
I mean,
I,
uh,
I get asked that a lot and I think
people,
um,
people expect me to say,
well,
you know,
it was just this,
it was just this huge relief off your
shoulders when you,
when you talked to oprah or you or
whatever you did that,
that you can now move forward and live
the life of an honest man and et Cetera,
et cetera.
But it's taken me,
let me just sum it up.
I mean,
sitting here today,
having this conversation,
I would much prefer to have this
conversation then the one where I would
align to your fucking face 15 times,
10 years ago,
I'd much rather us talk like this.
So that's,
that's a relief.
Um,
but it,
but it was,
you know,
it's not like I walked out of sitting
with Oprah and was like,
oh my God,
I feel amazing.
That was,
that was an ass weapon.
And,
uh,
so was it like sitting there with Oprah?
She's asking,
she's drilling you,
ask you questions about that start.
She came out,
she came out hot,
yes or no.
Yes or no.
The one,
yes or no.
That's it.
I thought she did a good job.
She did a great job.
I thought it was very compelling because
the way she structured the beginning
part of the conversation.
Yeah.
Especially if you're going to do
something like that on television.
You want to capture people and keep them
there.
You kind of have to approach it that
way.
I thought she did a good job.
I,
I don't,
I know that it wasn't well received and
I,
and I lean in what way?
You mean people didn't like you
afterwards and that way he wasn't low
risk.
I think there's two things.
Number one,
I,
I wasn't emotionally ready to do that
interview.
I wasn't,
uh,
I wasn't in a place where I think that I
sit today where it's,
it is a position of contrition and
understanding the tremendous sense of
betrayal that's out there.
Like my perception of that today is much
sharper than it was three years ago when
I sat with her.
The feds and other lawsuits forced my
hand.
I had to sit there with that cause I
knew I was going to be sitting with her
or with you or with Tom Brokaw hall or I
was going to be sitting with a
government lawyer being deposed,
being videoed and being leaked.
So I said,
well,
I'm going to go,
I'm going to find the place that I'd
rather sit down and talk about this as
opposed to a grainy video that the
government leaks to the world and that's
your coming out party.
So I did that.
But the,
the thing about Oprah is,
is aside from me just not being ready at
the time to do it,
you know,
people sensed that.
But most importantly for the diehard
cycling fans and sports fans,
I didn't say enough.
You didn't name names.
He didn't,
you didn't call anybody out.
[inaudible] wasn't detailed enough.
You're holding back.
You're protecting people.
That's what they said.
That's a very small percentage of the
population for the majority of the
population.
Those first five minutes was way too
much information.
They were like,
what the fuck did I just hear?
Like blood bags hipo testosterone
transfusions,
cheating.
It was way too much.
So you had people that were at one camp,
a smaller camp said he didn't say it.
Now he's holding back here,
the other campus like,
all right,
that's,
that's more than I needed to hear.
And so everybody was pissed.
Well,
I don't know why they would think it's
too much.
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't understand that logic because it
is reality or grandma
duluth.
Right.
And,
and you and you supported the cancer.
So
survivor clause isn't real and you hear
that.
I mean,
you're sitting there going,
ah,
I don't,
I don't like anything about this.
So the,
uh,
so I see,
because they were also supporting lives,
drawing,
yeah.
Also supporting the stores.
How much of an effect did it have like
almost immediately on your foundation?
I don't know,
because I was asked to leave the
foundation before that and said,
and I haven't been back,
so I don't know.
And I'm not,
and I don't ask,
is it still around?
Yeah.
But it must've taken a devastating,
right?
I think so.
I mean it takes a hit in terms of,
uh,
obviously in terms of fundraising,
which directly leads to its,
you know,
its effectiveness in terms of helping
create change for cancer survivors are
all around the world.
You need to raise money in order to do
that.
Um,
staff layoffs.
Uh,
I mean,
you name it.
I mean it,
it's uh,
but,
but I don't,
I don't have specifics because once I
left the board and left the organization
and they legally changed the name,
I mean,
I dunno,
it,
none of it was shocking to me.
Um,
I mean,
I knew,
I didn't know,
but I knew that every,
I have a friend who was a professional
cycler,
just say his name is John Cyclist.
Cyclist.
Sorry.
We're going to get this right.
Let me see.
Okay.
People,
I'm going to write it down.
Cyclist.
Yeah.
He's up by,
some people say the ultimate fighting
challenge.
It's championship.
Um,
and see,
I would say that.
Yeah,
but challenge.
Okay.
It's okay.
My friend John was a professional
cyclist.
Yup.
And,
uh,
this was,
2000,
maybe three,
three,
four.
And,
um,
he told me,
he was like,
listen man,
we were all,
we're all on it.
He goes,
guys would get off the bus in the middle
of the night.
You'd hear them taking off their bikes
and going for a ride because their blood
got too thick.
There are those old stories.
Yeah,
that's from EPL,
right?
It,
that's a,
yeah,
I've heard those stories.
I never,
I never saw that,
but well,
so my friend John,
I mean maybe it was on the crazy team or
something like that.
And back in the day before they got it
dialed in.
Well,
what they,
what happened was,
is there was no test,
right?
So no sport had a test,
whether it's cycling or swimming or
running or boxing or who,
whatever sport is using epo.
They didn't have a test for EPO.
And so they,
uh,
and with,
you know,
one of the side effects of epo or,
or you know,
or increasing your red cell count is
your blood.
It's,
it's literally a question of viscosity,
right?
So all your oil and your hotel royal.
Yeah.
Well,
that's the only time you ever think of
the word viscosity,
right,
is your motor oil.
But more red cells means thicker blood.
Your blood is too thick.
We know what happens.
It's not,
it isn't a good thing.
And so the sport had to go to,
they couldn't test for the science
wasn't there yet.
So they went to these sort of
preventative screening methods,
right?
So then they started testing the
viscosity or the thickness of people's
bloods,
otherwise known as hematocrit.
Right?
Um,
and so that they would use that as a
screen.
Anybody above 50% hematocrit couldn't
race that you weren't positive,
you didn't get banned,
but you were put on the side for two
weeks as a,
as a health measure,
anyone under 50% it was fine to race.
So everybody took that is,
I mean,
before that there were people that were
60,
64%.
Those guys might be getting up in the
middle of the night going for a little
spin,
but at 50,
you know,
they deemed that sort of the healthiest
level,
you know,
but people pushed it right up to 50.
Then there's,
and there's some side effects and
there's some possible potential health
risks as far as like strokes and things
along those lines.
I'm sure.
Did anybody that was on the tour ever
dropped dead from epo?
Well,
there's,
there,
there was,
you know,
look,
they're there.
I don't know.
I mean there are a lot of documented
cases,
especially in the 80s,
right.
When hipo I guess was first hitting the
scene.
There was this wave of Dutch cyclists
that passed away in the night and you
know,
in the night,
huh.
In their sleep.
And that's probably when it would
happen.
Well,
I dunno,
I mean,
I,
I didn't,
I didn't do the autopsy,
you know,
nobody,
I don't know if anybody's ever proven
that,
but that,
that's sort of,
um,
I don't want to say that was the myth,
but that was,
uh,
that Eco,
the drug took the blame for those
deaths.
And so it hasn't happened since and it
didn't happen,
uh,
in,
you know,
in our generation.
But
I don't know.
But my point being that it can be fairly
dangerous.
Well if,
well if your blood,
yeah,
you can imagine if it gets to the SEC.
So at that,
that would not be one of the things that
it didn't surprise me that,
uh,
when,
when you came clean,
I was like,
well good for him.
That was really what I thought.
I was like,
it's kind of fucked up that he was lying
all this time and it's kind of fucked up
that he was suing people that were
saying that he was telling lies and,
but one of the things that shocked me
the most,
well,
I was thinking about it,
was that you,
you had recovered from cancer.
You had one of your testicles removed.
He had brain surgery,
lung cancer.
You mean your,
your body was ravaged by this and yet
you still were taking drugs.
Yup.
That's,
that's what got me,
I was like that what a crazy desire to
win that you,
you got to this place where your body
was,
you know,
you were on death's door and recover
from it and then put yourself back and
wrist.
Right?
Yup.
I mean,
yeah,
saying it like that it,
it,
there's no,
there's no justifying that other than
you,
I was in this sport that,
that I really wanted to,
to,
to be in and stay in and after the
disease I wanted to go back to,
and that was the,
that was the landscape.
And so you viewed it,
you thought,
okay,
this is not ideal,
but you asked the question,
what am I really,
you know,
having,
knowing my health history,
right,
with cancer,
with all the,
all that I went through is going back to
my sport and taking epo a risk to that,
to that,
you know,
to my,
to my disease or to my health.
Um,
and I,
and the answer to that,
obviously my answer to myself was,
no,
you really didn't think that it was a
risk to push your body like that.
And,
and to put all these,
you mean stuff,
they're there.
They're in a lot of ways,
they're pushing your body in an
unnatural way or to an unnatural level.
Testosterone and human growth hormone
epo and all these and that.
Sheila really,
and that's the only difference that that
was made was,
I mean,
I had a slight experience with growth
hormone before the disease and then
after,
after the diagnosis and the treatment
and recovery,
I said,
okay,
that,
that does not sound like a good idea.
It's too dangerous.
And perhaps in my own fucked up way,
I was thinking,
well,
that would lead to the growth of a,
have to have most of,
you know,
a malignant cell,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So,
um,
but I didn't,
I didn't view those two the simplest.
I don't,
I don't think hgh is for cycling.
I don't think it's very effective
anyways.
I think it's a waste.
Did you alter your diet?
Well,
for sure.
Yeah.
But what changes did you make when you,
uh,
when you came back from having cancer?
Man,
I was,
and again,
this is the stuff that we can talk
about.
I talked about forever and you know,
and it's almost sort of mocked now.
You know,
cause we talked about the change in diet
and the increased,
you know,
intensity of training and the
reconnaissance and the technology and
the wind tunnel.
And we did all of those things and they
all worked,
you know.
But I say their mock now because people
now know the truth.
We all know the truth.
And people say,
oh,
he told us it was all that other
bullshit.
He told us it was the training.
He told us it was his diet.
Well now we know it was just the doping.
Um,
well it wasn't though.
There's the doping end.
That was the last,
that was the final piece,
which just was unfortunately isn't it?
Was it,
as we've said numerous times,
it's just an,
it was unfortunate and it was
inevitable.
Um,
but that was the final piece and the,
and it was also the piece that we never
talked about.
Of course,
of course.
Yeah.
So this is the weight you're carrying
around.
I,
I'm what I'm asking you about your die.
I literally didn't know that you had
discussed this ad nauseum.
Yeah.
So you're,
you're carrying this around.
You're always assuming that if you look
at me racing in [inaudible] 96 before I
was diagnosed,
and then you look at me winning the tour
[inaudible] 99,
I missed 20 pounds difference.
So I mean,
I went and I had this when I got out of,
uh,
sort of my cancer mission,
you know,
and,
and recovered and took a year and a half
away and went back.
I view,
I mean,
I viewed racing bikes as life,
life and death.
I viewed it,
I viewed my disease as a,
as a competitive event,
as a sporting event.
It's me versus the opposition,
looking at the scoreboard,
how we doing.
And then when I got to,
uh,
when I got back on the bike,
it was,
it was like life and death and so
everything was intensified.
Starving yourself,
training your ass off,
just being,
as you said a minute ago,
just being generally fucking totally
crazy for,
for a result.
Mad,
not mad,
but madness.
You were starving yourself to be
lighter.
Yeah.
Well that's part of it.
I mean these
poor guys down and there,
there are a lot skinnier than we were.
I mean this has guys ride in five,
six hours a day and not eating.
I mean it just,
it just fucking sucks.
How do they do it?
You don't eat this?
Just,
just,
just deal with it.
Just go to bed hungry.
Wow.
Just to keep your body weight light.
It's all power to weight.
Wish she were still,
I wish I would like to know what the
fuck these guys are doing now.
I would like to know when you see guys
with faster times and really
ridiculously stringent drug testing.
Yeah.
Well anytime I go anywhere near that I
just get,
I just get destroyed because um,
I don't know.
The,
the,
the people view it as,
as me accusing them.
I mean I've,
I've made,
cause I get a lot,
a lot of questions.
Fall tweet backs.
I don't ask me,
I have no idea.
You know,
people take that as saying,
well,
he just,
he just blamed them.
He just accused them of doing the same
shit.
And I feel bad for those guys.
Man.
I feel I feel bad for any top level
rider that that is racing their bike in
2015 and has to answer questions about a
guy from 1999 like if I was winning in
[inaudible] 99 and what is that 16
years?
If somebody asks me a question about
somebody from 1983 I said,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Don't ask me that question.
Like why are you asking me?
Well some do 20 years ago.
I'm here today.
So,
but it's
well that's the craziest thing about you
and the sport.
You are inexorably tied to it.
There's no way to pull it away from you.
Like that scandal was one of the,
at least in the United States,
it was one of the biggest aspects of
that sport ever.
It's still,
I mean it any,
any,
any story that gets written.
I mean saw,
I don't if you fall of track and field
or all of this stuff that came out of
Ben Johnson,
too old,
but there's,
there was just this revelation that came
out of international track and field and
the Russian Federation and the covers up
there and all of those stories that get
written,
whether it's on deadspin or the New York
Times or on twitter,
they all reference the story as well,
so you get put back,
which is,
I don't know if that's a good or a bad
thing,
but it just,
it,
it brings people back to that,
you know,
to my history.
Yeah.
It's like it's baseball and Barry bonds
and it's just,
there are tied,
there's just no way they're going to,
you're going to separate the two of them
together.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's got to be a very bizarre thing for
those people that are racing.
Hmm.
That's them.
Yeah.
You should,
don't want,
they don't want to,
so he knows who they are.
That's the most fucked up thing about
it.
It's like you're like,
I mean in a way like Tony Hawk is the
only skateboarder I have ever heard of.
It's the only,
I mean I'm sure I've met a few other
ones,
but I don't know.
I don't remember their names.
Yeah,
but Tony Hawk is that guy like you think
a skateboarding thing?
Could Tony Hobbit,
you think of bike racing?
I think of Lance Armstrong and now that
you think of swimming,
you think of Michael Phelps?
Yeah.
It's just,
yeah,
there's a few,
well,
Greg Lamont is a diver.
You think of him,
I guess he's kind of a swimmer.
These buttons on this.
Greg,
Greg Gain Louganis sorry,
I'm going to pay attention.
At least you said cyclist.
I did.
I'm getting better.
Greg.
Greg Lamont's probably like what the
fuck?
Yeah,
there's just,
it's weird when you have a sport that's
where the public locks onto one person
and they don't know any of the other
people.
And like if it's football,
there's like fucking hundreds of guys
boxing hundreds of guys.
But with cycling there's just so few and
you carrying the weight of that sport in
the United States.
Trying to popularize it and as well as a
holding onto this lie.
Yep.
Yup.
Yeah.
Dope.
I mean,
I mean that when I hear you say that,
I mean it,
it,
and you may not be defending me,
but it sounds as if you're defending me.
So I don't,
I don't necessarily want,
yeah.
That I'm not defending you.
Right.
What I'm doing and I'm trying to
aluminate reality in a pretty objective
way.
Well,
you could do that on your next podcast
because me sitting here right now each
uncomfortable,
no,
it doesn't make me uncomfortable,
but I,
I'm,
I'm of the belief that nobody wants to
hear that shit.
That there's still,
I think people are upset.
I know they're upset.
So
some people do.
I mean,
look,
did you get,
you gotta have people that are upset?
Well,
I think what we're dealing with when it
comes to the Internet is just a gigantic
number of people.
There's too many people to like say,
some people aren't this,
but he can't,
he can't manage it.
There's hundreds of millions of people
who can get on their facebook or get on
the twitter and just start giving their
input right now.
And that's never happened before.
And when that happens,
you're going to be understandably
sensitive to the outcome.
Yup.
Yeah.
What was the blow back like?
Like when you,
when you did the oprah thing and then
you just went out into the public,
did you just try to lay low for awhile?
Yeah,
I tried to,
well,
there was,
there was several variations of quote
unquote blowback or there was just the
public's perception.
So if I walked down the street,
which I have to admit was,
was better than I expected.
Right?
Peep nobody.
It's not as if I left talking with Oprah
and I walked out on the street and you
know,
people were throwing shit at me.
I mean,
that just,
that's never happened.
Could happen one day,
but it hasn't yet.
There's the blow back,
which is the most important part,
which is the way my kids were treated.
You know,
I've got five kids,
three older ones.
Um,
you know,
I was very concerned with what they
heard in the hallways,
you know,
what they,
what they saw and their social media
stuff.
Um,
you know,
what,
what is,
what does that news due to them that is
the most important thing.
And it's a real credit to the city of
Austin and the schools that they go to
our community and their friends and the
kids in the school very little blow
back.
So that was,
for me,
that was,
that was like the biggest relief.
Like people can throw shit at me and say
shit all day long,
but if my kids were treated roughly,
I mean,
that would just,
that would break your heart when it,
I mean devastating.
Yeah,
that'd be the,
by far the worst.
So that was,
um,
that was very fortunate that,
that there was not seamless.
I mean,
there was some stuff,
but they managed it and we managed it in
the community,
managed it pretty well.
And then there was the legal blow back,
which was,
uh,
which was pretty nasty.
I mean,
I,
I got there as soon as I stepped off the
stage with Oprah,
call it a stage,
um,
the lawsuit just piled up and piled up
big.
And how many of them are still ongoing
right now?
Just one,
just one.
One the federal government when the
federal case and the federal [inaudible]
they were,
but there were,
and some of them were,
were,
were highly publicized.
Uh,
and some were not some,
the problem,
the team was,
uh,
insuring all of my salaries and all of
my bonuses unbeknownst to me.
And so because they didn't have the
money.
And so when this goes down,
all of these companies came back and
said,
where's our money?
And I said,
well,
who are you?
I said,
well,
we're so the team,
I knew about one situation,
right?
The big one,
the SCA case,
which,
uh,
which has been settled since,
but there were many,
many others and some were public,
some were private.
Um,
but they all had to get settled.
And so we've navigated that landscape
and now we're just down to the postal
case,
the federal case.
And when is that going to be resolved?
Um,
that's a good question.
It's been going on a long time.
Uh,
and it came on the heels of a two or
three year criminal investigation,
which you're well aware of through
there,
Jeff Novitsky and through the US
Attorney's office here in Los Angeles.
So once that case was closed,
then the civil division picked up the
postal case.
And it's been ongoing for years.
And,
and
you know,
we sort of finished that first phase of
litigation and that it'll go to trial
maybe a year from now in Washington DC.
We talked about this very briefly before
the podcast.
We wanted to kind of save it for the
podcast.
I don't understand the criminal
investigation.
I don't understand the allocation of
resources towards someone who was bike
racing.
I feel like in a world where we have
bankers that causes gigantic 2008
financial collapse,
we have pharmaceutical companies are
making billions of dollars.
Getting people hooked on Oxycontin is
when we have crime and murder and all
the fucking problems we have in this
culture to spend taxpayers' dollars on
bike racing.
A guy who may have cheated or definitely
cheated in a sport where everybody's
cheating.
Yup.
That seems kind of fun.
Well,
you can,
it's mccarthyism.
I mean,
you can have,
uh,
first of all,
cyclists don't have any lobbyists.
Nobody's out protecting us.
W W W whatever we did or didn't do in
Europe 20 years ago,
the banks do,
big Pharma does,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So that's kind of a good old boys club
that,
that we're not a part of.
But,
and,
and we've talked about this offline.
I mean,
when you,
when you have a federal agent in a guy
like Novitsky whose,
whose,
he has made his career with these types
of cases,
whether it's balco or bonds or Marion
Jones,
um,
uh,
when you have a guy like that,
that,
that all of a sudden is interested,
it's gonna happen.
You know?
And,
and when you have that,
you know,
particular agent or any agent that walks
into a interview,
a witness or interview,
an old teammate with a badge and a gun,
they're talking,
yeah,
it gets weird,
right?
Yeah.
They don't just kind of investigation.
It's so of course you,
I mean,
I know,
I heard what you said.
Of course.
I don't think it makes much sense,
but I'm,
I was at,
I was in the cross hairs.
So people are going to say,
well,
of course you don't think it makes
sense,
but,
um,
look,
I mean,
uh,
and I,
and I listened to your,
to your podcast with Novitsky and,
uh,
I mean
it's just,
uh,
there's some bullshit in there.
And so what specifically,
um,
you know,
I think the idea that,
that,
uh,
and I,
and again,
I'm not,
I don't work for the government.
I don't work for the US Attorney's
office here,
but I think the idea that he was brought
into the investigation,
I don't know that that's necessarily
true.
I think,
um,
and again,
I don't know Jeff,
but I think he went,
I think he looked for those cases.
I mean,
he,
and whether or not,
and by the way,
when you're an agent for the food and
Drug Administration,
I don't know how,
I mean,
all of these things have missions.
He was,
you know,
he was an agent for the irs.
And so then that's when balco and bond
started.
I don't,
I dunno,
the doping and baseball as an irs issue.
I Dunno that doping in cycling 20 years
ago is an issue for the FDA.
I mean,
they regulate who makes aspirin and who
gives you your lettuce and your eggs and
what does that have to do with,
but I think he,
I think he was opportunistic when it
came to,
uh,
these cases,
whether it's barry bonds or myself.
Um,
and,
and you know,
he,
he thrived on that.
Well,
I think you look at it two ways in one
on one hand,
he certainly capitalizes on these high
profile cases.
He certainly goes after that.
I'm on the other hand,
him capitalizing and being the,
the rabbit investigator that he is,
it highlights the issues that are going
on.
Sure.
So the,
I think the real problems,
the allocation of money,
like how much money is being spent on
these cases.
You know,
he told me that the barry bonds case,
they only spent like $100,000.
I didn't,
I didn't expect that.
I didn't question them and I didn't
research it beforehand.
I didn't,
I didn't know that that was even going
to come up.
But then once I did research it,
it seems like it was a a fuck load.
More money than $100,000.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's obviously that's laughable,
but,
uh,
whatever the number was,
it,
you know,
it wasn't a hundred thousand,
but it was,
it was probably not as much as what was
reported.
Um,
but
hey,
that's a,
that's the United States of America.
That's what they get to do.
And also you get a guy like him,
and that's how these issues get
highlighted.
And that's why we know about it because
he was so aggressive in his tactics.
He was so aggressive and chasing down
anybody that he thought was doing these
drugs.
That's why we know about these cases.
And it's such an extreme detail.
Yup.
Yeah,
yeah.
Man,
it was,
uh,
it wasn't pleasant watching that are
listening to that podcast.
I mean,
and the fact that the,
I don't know if you're bullshitting me
or not,
the fact that he wanted to do the
podcast with me.
Oh he did?
Yeah.
He asked to do it.
Well,
what kind of crazy is that?
I think he wanted to find out like how
do we felt about it,
what it feels like now.
You know,
he wants to,
I mean it,
it needs ongoing.
I mean,
he works right now doing drug
investigations for the UFC and he's done
a fantastic job to the point where,
as I was telling you before the podcast,
we've seen radical changes in fighters
physiques and their performances.
Guys like guys who were world beaters
have dropped off substantially.
There's the word in the mixed martial
arts community.
When I talked to fighters,
when I talked to trainers,
he's had a gigantic impact and they're
terrified because they've imposed these
very strict,
uh,
fines and a probationary periods.
Yep.
And as you also said before the podcast,
I mean,
you have a sport where,
you know,
the bigger and stronger your physically,
the more you're pummeling somebody
else's head in.
Yes.
It's different.
Yeah.
It's different than his stall.
It is definitely different.
I think it's much more,
it's much more important.
Is this sport just as exciting?
It's pretty damn exciting.
So it's hard to say if it's just as
exciting or not.
Cause I think there's a lot of great
fighters who were world champions who
are clean cut.
It's just a,
it's like some of the all time greats.
I mean,
there's great guys right now,
Frankie Edgar clean as a whistle.
Chris Weidman,
very clean,
rockhold clean,
who's the new champion in the
middleweight division.
There's a lot of great fighters that are
clean.
It's a,
um,
it's hard to tell.
There's a lot of fighters who weren't
clean,
who are fucking awesome when they
weren't clean.
Vito Belfort,
who,
uh,
went on this wild run for like a,
at 36 years old when he a w they had,
this is one of the apartments.
One of the big problems with the UFC was
that they had legal testosterone
replacement for a short period of time
for a few years and guys were just
fucking juice into the tits.
They didn't like it was skittles.
Oh,
they would come back with these hyper
human level so that they would test them
and you know,
like a normal person in your
testosterone level would be like a low
three,
high eight,
800.
Vito was like 1,475 and he looked like a
fucking silver back and just hyper
aggressive,
super confident.
That's different,
you know,
that's,
that's dangerous.
And winning and beating guys to,
you know,
to a pulp,
right.
That's a,
that's a different situation.
It's it,
you know,
you're not talking about an extreme
endurance sport like that.
Like that kind of aggression and
explosion wouldn't benefit you in
cycling because it's such a long
endurance race.
And also the,
the benefit isn't the end result is in
someone,
someone's health doesn't get compromised
by it.
Yup.
Yeah.
So,
yeah.
So I mean that's,
I don't know that sport that well and,
and I don't know what people's feelings
are in and amongst the sport.
I mean,
you just give a pretty good perspective
on it.
So,
uh,
more power to him there.
It's just,
it's messy to pull it out.
It's messy because it was so pervasive.
It's like if they had figured out it's
if,
if the tour,
if half the guys were clean and half the
guys were dirty,
the Tour de France,
and then they figured out how to pull
the drugs out from half,
it would be messy.
Right,
because then it'd be like,
okay,
well why?
What happened?
Why were these guys doing so well and
now they're not the guys who are winning
or not winning,
but if they,
the tour seems like it's so pervasive
that if they pull the drugs out,
the same guys would be winning the
times.
It'd be slower
but,
but what happened?
What happened was primarily I guess the
Dude Novitsky his investigation,
which which when was closed,
he more or less handed everything to you
saw it,
you saw the picked up the investigation
and then they acted.
They gave me the lifetime ban that left,
like when the world reads that in 2012,
it was the summer of 2012 the world
reads that the impression is,
or when I do oprah,
for example,
which has three or four months later,
the impression is that we were hanging a
blood bag six months ago.
Like it's a current event.
It feels,
although it had been,
it had been seven years before any line
had ever been crossed ever,
even during the compact.
So,
but it made it current.
The comeback made it current for people.
Novitsky investigating,
uh,
getting everybody to speak through his
own tactics.
Um,
it made it a current event when it,
when it really,
it really wasn't.
It's like,
it's like,
uh,
I remember sitting there in 2012
thinking,
or the shit's going down.
This is,
this is unbelievable.
Being in the middle of it being me,
this is unreal.
And I thought,
you know,
and,
and we're talking about 1999 through
2005,
but let's use 99 as,
as an example.
I remember thinking to myself,
who won the superbowl in [inaudible] 99
and it was the,
the broncos and elway was the MVP.
I remember thinking to myself,
what if I open the paper today and the
NFL is opened a case against John La in
2012.
I would have read that and gone,
this is a joke,
right?
He said,
April fools.
Like what the fuck?
It isn't like an old guy who stands on
the sideline now.
Like,
so it just,
they were able to go way,
way back and,
and,
and sidestep and ignore any sort of due
process and statute of limitations and
they made it a current event.
I'm not,
I'm not blaming them or defending
myself.
I'm just telling you what happened.
And uh,
you know,
that,
is not totally accurate,
but
well,
it's because it was so long.
It went on for so long.
Like you remember they had that Nike
commercial when that Nike Commercial,
when you were doing it live strong Nike,
Nike commercial and you're,
you're riding your bike and you're
talking about people calling you a
doper.
This is before you had come clean.
That was in 2000 yeah.
And this is,
this is before,
you'd never failed any tests.
There was not,
but you still had to address it in a
fucking Nike commercial.
Yeah.
So this was,
this was something that was,
it was ill advised.
Yeah,
it seems,
but that's again,
I mean all of this,
whether it's
agreeing to that commercial or the way
you treated,
I needed,
you know,
somebody in my life to go,
I,
I just read this script or this
storyboard and I think that's a real bad
idea.
But did you have anybody like that in
your life?
Well,
clearly not,
but did anybody suggest it?
No.
No one but no.
But,
but I was,
but isn't that hard though,
because you're such a fucking winner.
You're lucky you're on top of that
world.
Nobody wants to say,
hey man,
don't do that
dude.
It's like when you're,
when you're in that position,
nobody,
everybody's saying yes,
yes,
of course.
Yes.
That's a great idea.
Lance.
Yes,
absolutely.
Right now,
yes.
It.
Then nobody's sitting there playing the
devil's advocate or saying,
I think that's a bad idea.
There's,
I didn't have that north star man and,
and again,
I'm not,
the fucking buck stops with me,
man.
I should have been mature enough and
worldly enough to go
bad idea.
Let's make another commercial are bad
idea.
Lance.
Let's say something else in the next
press conference.
But it seems like the,
the weight of it all in the air of it
all was so thick that you kind of had to
address it all the time because it was
being thrown at you all the time.
I was,
I peripherally watched cycling
peripherally and I knew about it.
Everyone knew about it right on
it,
but,
but it,
but the more defensive I became and the
more aggressive I became in the denials,
all that does,
right,
is what it might a piece.
Some people are support is good lad.
Did you,
I heard it in his voice.
I believe that.
But what it really did,
especially with the press was it just,
it just made the next occasion,
the next question,
the next episode even more inevitable.
Like it just,
it added fuel to that fire.
Like you know,
looking back in hindsight,
I should've just said like,
I'm not going not gonna talk about it or
whatever the answer was.
But instead of saying,
you know,
it was literally like finger in your
chest,
fuck you don't ask me that.
I mean that is when you're guilty.
That's a real bad approach and it's the
one that I took and quite honestly it's,
you know,
probably one of the main reasons that,
that we're sitting here today talking
about this.
Why do you think you took that approach
when looking back on it?
Because I,
because that is the approach that I took
and training and in racing and even,
I mean these are guys that I raced
against that I liked,
but I would make up reasons to fucking
hate him.
Like I'd read something and be like,
look at this asshole.
Did you read what he's,
I mean he probably didn't even say
anything.
I'd take it.
I'd be like,
I can't believe he said just as fuel.
Just his motivation.
So that's all fine and good when you're
training and your racing.
And you're competing,
but when you step off the bike that you
have to have that switch to say,
okay,
that's been done.
You won the written,
don't,
we're not going to go treat another
human being that way.
Right.
And,
and just uh,
in a professional context or in a press
context,
you gotta turn it off,
man.
And I couldn't,
like I was,
I had my finger in people's chest on the
bike,
off the bike everywhere.
And so
my bad dude,
I mean,
I,
I didn't have the,
the ability to turn that off.
I mean,
it's good to be a competitor,
but it's not good to be too competitive.
And once you start,
once you took that approach,
once you started with that approach,
did you feel like there was like a
weight of momentum behind you?
Like to dig your heels in and stop it
and try a new approach would be very
difficult.
Well,
yeah,
once,
once it gets rolling,
it's,
it's tough to ducted.
Halter,
what was it like with the people that
you were close to?
Obviously the people that you trained
with,
they knew what you were doing,
but what about your family and your
close friends?
How many of them were aware of what was
going on?
I think by and large,
I don't know.
I wouldn't have asked him and they
wouldn't have asked me.
I think it was sort of this to your
friends.
Never add any land,
man.
Come on.
I think it's more donate ever pulled you
aside?
Don't ask.
Don't tell.
Really.
Yeah,
probably.
You know they probably didn't.
They didn't want to know.
Do you have close friends outside of
cycling?
Yes.
And they didn't ask you?
Yeah.
Well no they didn't,
but really,
I mean they might also ride bikes so
they're not in the sport,
but,
but yeah,
nobody sat at the bar.
I was like,
dude,
come on.
Yeah,
no one.
No.
Wow.
That's fucking crazy.
If I was your friend,
dude,
I would've got you fucked up.
I was just going to say,
you got you drunk.
I'm like,
come on dude,
we're going on a hike.
You're Joe Joe,
Joe.
We'd be talking about it now.
He's like,
I would have,
I remember that time I got him all
fucked up and he admitted it.
I would've never said a word until you
came out.
Once he came out,
then I woulda told until the guy with
the badge and the gun showed up and then
you would have said everything.
I would have ducked Jeff Novitsky.
Yeah.
No,
I would have hired some lawyers.
I believe.
You got to sit with me when this guy
comes in.
What's going on?
What do you want to know?
Nobody bike racing mocked it.
Nobody bike.
Bike racing like a kid's bike and what?
You have a gun?
Someone stealing bikes?
No,
they're the killing people with bikes.
The fuck's going on with that gun?
Yeah.
What happens in these podcasts when,
when?
When the interviewee has to take a leak.
You go take a leak,
man.
Don't worry.
What happens to the podcast?
We'll just pause it for a second.
What about the people at home?
I'll talk to them.
Don't worry about,
oh yeah,
that's right.
You're also here too.
Don't worry about it,
man.
Go take a leak.
Happens all the time.
It's no big deal.
Really?
Yeah.
Okay.
All the time.
Don't sweat.
Well,
I'm going to go take it.
Go take a leak.
Please do.
Just one thing about athletes,
they drink.
Fuck loads of water lenses here
pounding.
He's hung over to,
here's a very specific schedule.
He told me he drinks two cups of coffee
in the morning.
Then it takes a shit and he drinks water
all day and then he waits until about
five,
about five.
Then he started drinking.
That's a good drug.
I was going to ask him about marijuana
cause if he smoked marijuana and he was
holding in all those lies,
that shit would fuck with you.
Like I'll smoke some weed and uh,
I'll think about a lie.
I told them highschool,
I don't fuck with me
really well.
I'll think about some shit that I did in
high school and make me go,
oh,
why the fuck did I say that?
Like it net.
That's the one of the crazy things about
marijuana and never lets you forget.
It'll bring those things up to you
trying to hide.
But alcohol.
Alcohol is like,
Eh,
don't worry about it.
Buzzy alcohol is the best drug.
If you're trying to hold back a lie,
just throw that down.
And you know,
as soon as you can't walk straight,
you're thinking about that.
As soon as you're,
you know,
you're,
you're thinking about the song was
playing,
you're thinking about your whatever
you're thinking about other things.
It's good.
It's a good close your focus drug.
Whereas pot is the opposite.
Pot is a open your focus.
This is fascinating though,
isn't a Jamie forget you have a secret.
Yeah.
You forget.
You don't give a fuck about your
secrets.
I mean,
that's why people make horrible sexual
decisions when they're drunk.
You know?
I mean,
it's also why people think that people
that are drunk shouldn't,
you shouldn't have sex with someone
who's drunk,
even if you're drunk.
I mean,
that's why they're the crazy feminist
tried to say that that's rape and ended
up man and woman have sex in there
drunk.
It's rape while they say it.
Because you're obviously not exactly of
sound.
I mean it depends on how drunk you are,
right?
But at a certain level,
you're certainly impaired and you can't
make good decisions.
It's like,
it's funny though,
that a guy who was just such a,
an athlete,
lifelong athlete,
fucking pounds,
UCC like that.
And ask him how long does it,
we were talking about marijuana and
whether or not,
uh,
you used marijuana while you were a
holding back all those lies and how it
would fuck with you.
Because when I was,
I'll think I'll get high and I'll think
about some shit I lied about in high
school and it will go like,
oh,
paranoia.
And it'll illuminate areas of your life
that you're trying to,
uh,
avoid.
Hmm.
The economy of all this is a fascinating
aspect of it because there were a lot of
people that were making money off of you
racing a lot of people.
There's a gigantic industry.
And for them to pretend that they didn't
know what I knew as a fucking comedian
who w again,
peripherally watch cycling,
you know,
I'd watch you win and I be like,
damn,
that motherfucker want again.
Damn.
That's it.
You know,
I mean,
I'd,
I'd never raced raced bikes.
I never rode bikes is so for me and I
knew,
you know,
I'm like,
how the fuck does the US post office not
know?
How the fuck does Nike not know how the
fuck does they know?
They know.
They can pretend they don't know,
but they know if they didn't,
if they didn't know then they're
irresponsible.
It's irresponsible.
But they kind of knew and they just
said,
it's all right.
We're getting away with it.
We are getting away with it.
But then once the shit came down,
then they all wanted their money back.
Yeah.
Well
that's a weird aspect.
You can't talk too much about this,
right?
That one.
Yeah.
I wouldn't get sensitive for the post
office one.
Tricky.
Definitely toughest one.
I know you can't talk about it,
but can you talk about this is this is a
reality when you are accused of
defrauding the federal government,
which is what they're saying because you
were riding for the US post office,
that was the team and you won x amount
of money during that time.
They,
they can sue you for three times that
money.
Correct.
Right.
So they want a hundred million bucks.
Yeah.
A lot of money.
How's that going?
That's uh,
you know,
honestly it didn't,
that's it.
That's the only active case.
So that one does get a little trickier
to talk about just from a,
uh,
I don't want to be crushed by my
lawyers,
but we like our case.
W W we think that,
uh,
we're,
we're confident in the case.
We believe that the postal service a
while none of this story is,
is,
uh,
is perfect.
Um,
we believe that the postal service and
the,
and their own numbers support it.
I mean the Postal Service Commission
three separate studies to,
to analyze the effect of the sponsorship
on the team.
Uh,
we believe they made hundreds of
millions of dollars and,
and we know that they were also using
the team as a sales vehicle.
So coming to the two during the tour,
bringing over potential new clients,
bringing over new clients there were
actually converting their business to
the postal service.
We know that happened and we know that
equaled a significant increase in
revenue.
So we like our case,
I mean,
and,
and at this point,
uh,
what I like to have all legal issues out
of my life.
Yes.
But settlements not an option.
And so we have to just fall back on what
we think is the strength of the case.
Does that,
if they made a ton of money while you
were being dishonest,
does that exonerate you from owing the
money?
Like how does that work?
Well,
I'm not a lawyer,
right?
My view of,
of of uh,
it's called a key tm case,
which is a false claims case.
My view is,
is,
and I think is one that,
that our side shares is it's about
damages,
right?
When was the postal service damaged and
what can we prove to be the damages?
And uh,
you know,
if there are no damages,
then I would like to think then there
was no case.
But it's,
it is what it is.
The federal government is interested in.
The Department of Justice is interested
in the case.
Uh,
and we,
and I have no choice but to fight it.
Uh,
I don't,
I don't have,
after the,
you know,
the dozen previous lawsuits,
I'm not in a position to,
to really cut any more checks.
And so I'm in a position where I have to
go,
I have to go fight this one out.
How do you get by financially now?
Um,
well the,
the first thing that,
that I did was,
was,
and I,
and I saw this coming into this,
what's going to happen is your life was
big.
I mean,
a three houses.
We had a jet.
I mean we had the whole,
so you just take that burn rate way
down.
So you just,
you're,
your overhead goes way down.
And you know,
the,
the crazy thing is,
is if you'd have told me before,
like,
you're going to go sell a bunch of shit
and so your plane,
I'm like,
dude,
that is life is going to suck.
Was that a plane?
Just,
you know,
the house and it was,
this is,
I'm not trying,
I'm not bragging,
I'm just telling you what really
happened.
And,
but I would've thought,
man,
this life is,
it's going to be terrible.
As you take it down and you live a
simpler life and you get your burn rate
down and you get it manageable.
Life's exactly the same.
Like I don't know.
I mean the happiness factor is exactly
the same.
None of that shit he's on that they've
done studies on the none of that shit.
It's more convenient.
Right.
Obviously getting going direct somewhere
and not dealing with a terminal and,
and you know,
fucking Tsa,
obviously that's different but it takes
some more time,
you know,
around more people.
But I'm just as happy as I was.
Heel.
They've done studies on people that
actually complicate their lives with
more success,
more houses,
more things in it actually makes you
more tense.
It gives you more to think about.
Well you got to,
yeah,
I mean you got to keep,
you know,
you have to feed that beast and so you
get a little bit of the dog Jason,
the tail going on and um,
you know,
life life was moving real,
real fast for me then.
And it moves a lot slower now.
Um,
which I don't,
I don't,
it might be a little slow for my taste
right now,
but I don't,
I didn't like it when it was that fast.
So you cut back on all the expenses and
what do you do?
You do earn money now?
Like what do you do to earn money?
You know,
occasionally.
So I'll,
I'll,
I still speak and sometimes,
uh,
I'm paid to speak.
Um,
and then they're just other,
other appearances.
I mean,
I still have some investments that,
that uh,
you know,
that help sort of ease that pain.
Um,
but you know,
and who knows what the future holds.
I don't know what,
what if that stuff dries up forever or
comes back or who knows?
What does it like to sit?
While this was all going on and watching
the economy of this story grow and
develop because it's not,
it wasn't just the,
the lawsuits.
There's also,
there's books,
there's documentaries is all these
television shows is all its focus.
There's ad revenue coming from those
shows,
is all these people that are dedicating
all this time,
like their careers become a big part of
their careers,
become telling the Lance Armstrong
story.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a small industry.
Yeah.
Um,
I mean there,
there was the industries that benefited
on the way up and I was one of those
industries.
There were the sponsor.
I mean,
you look at trek bicycles for example.
I mean before the first tour that I
think we did 125 million in sales.
I do a billion now.
So yeah,
it was big difference.
Um,
Eh,
so you have those sort of industries,
but then,
you know,
on the way down.
So those are all people are making money
on the way up and then on the way down,
uh,
yeah,
it's,
I think it's,
it did happen,
but it's probably normal and natural
that people capitalize on,
on the way down.
I mean,
look at Bill Clinton.
as he's going through everything he went
to,
believe me,
there were plenty of people going on
right now.
It's my turn to make some money and fair
play.
I mean that's just,
that's just the way it is.
And uh,
you know,
some people may think that's bs,
but shit,
I mean,
everybody was hopping on,
uh,
all the way down.
Well,
they have to write.
Yeah.
I mean it is a,
it was a gigantic story.
Now you're,
your friends did know what you were
doing when it came out.
How many of them had a hard time with
it?
How many of them were cool with it?
Like what was it like,
you
know,
it's,
yeah,
some,
I mean obviously the people,
you know,
the,
the sponsors fled,
right?
Did any of them stay?
No.
None.
How many did you have at a time?
Maybe 10.
But they have to leave.
Right?
I mean,
like some of them are publicly traded
companies,
so they have concerns about that.
Some of them are just covering their
ass,
whatever,
but they're all gone.
Um,
and friends are interesting.
I mean you have,
uh,
I mean,
just use the [inaudible] foundation is
as an example,
right?
I mean,
the,
I was on the board,
I was the chairman of the board,
I was the founder.
The board was my friends.
But these are the friends that say,
okay,
you're out.
And so I get it that,
that there might be a strategic reason
for that,
but then when you never hear from them,
then all of a sudden these people
disappear from your life.
I mean,
the way I sum it up is,
is anytime anybody goes through
anything,
and I don't know if you've had some
heavy shit in your life,
but when you're going through it,
people either lean in or they lean out
and some people lean out,
which means they run away.
And you're surprised by that and you're
like,
what the fuck?
I mean,
that guy was at every champagne party we
threw in Paris.
And right now he's like,
I've heard from the dude in three years.
Like,
that's strange.
Right?
Um,
but he probably has his own motivate,
either covering his own ass or maybe he
one of these people that has a
tremendous sense of betrayal and it's
just so pissed still and hurt.
And we have to,
I mean,
I have to be receptive to that.
Um,
but then they're the ones who lean in,
right?
And,
and most of those people don't surprise
you,
but then there are others that lean in
and they surprise.
You're like,
wow,
I didn't,
I didn't know you had my back like that.
And so you get surprised on both sides
and,
and at the end of it all,
dude,
you look around and you're like,
all right,
this,
if these people are here to these,
these are the people that are going to
ride anything out with me,
which is Kinda cool and refreshing for
me to,
to,
to really know,
right?
If you're,
if you're,
if you're in the,
if you're loading up a bus with all your
most loyal,
closest friends,
I fucking know who's on that bus now at
this point.
And for 20 years,
you know,
there was just a bunch of chumps that,
that,
that were on that bus.
But you know,
as soon as,
as soon as the,
the,
somebody changed the music,
they hopped off.
And so,
um,
and would tell you it takes adversity to
eliminate that no other way in until you
test them.
You really don't know.
Yeah.
Adversity.
I remember,
this is the funny quote,
we were,
this is a postal thing,
but we were,
once I was at,
I don't remember the postmaster
general's name,
his name at the time,
but we,
we did,
uh,
this totally unrelated,
but you said it versus saw it reminded
me he was introducing me at this thing
and he wanted to site,
you know,
introducing me.
He's overcome great adversity.
He says is lance,
he's,
he's overcome great diversity.
And I'm thinking,
Jesus White Kid from Plano,
I didn't overcome shit.
Whoops.
Um,
raising kids.
Yup.
Uh,
we both have children.
And obviously when you were raising your
kid,
you're teaching them about life,
you're trying to set an example.
Yep.
Um,
did you have to sit them down and
explain what was going on?
Um,
how old were your youngest at the time?
Oh,
and t,
uh,
the youngest we're wanting to,
whoa.
Yeah.
You didn't have to explain it.
So I've got,
I have three kids with my ex wife,
Kristen and Lucas,
now 16 and twin girls that are 14.
And then I have a six and a five year
old with Ana.
I'm bitten,
by the way.
All you know,
it's the craziest blended family you've
ever seen.
Like those five kids are five siblings.
It's,
it's the most beautiful thing.
And Anna and kristen are like sisters.
I mean,
it's,
I got a great situation.
That's awesome.
Awesome,
awesome.
It takes a lot of work,
but um,
or took a lot of work to get to this
place,
but it's awesome.
And Kristen,
to her credit was who I was married to
during this ugly period.
Um,
and who,
you know,
would obviously would have known
everything,
um,
has been great.
Whether it's,
whether it's conversations she's had
with our older children while were at
her house,
or just just helping massage this thing.
But I'm still sitting down with my kids.
I mean our whole,
you know,
I go to therapy and it goes,
we all go to them,
the kids go a week.
So we still sit down and just kind of
work this out.
Dude,
this is,
is is not,
this is a complicated thing.
And,
and,
and the crazy thing is my older kids
have kind of gotten through it.
The six and the five year old will come
into it,
right?
I mean the Internet and,
and you know,
fucking Google,
wikipedia,
you name it,
they're going to,
they will,
they will grow into this like at some
point,
my six year old boy who said just a
fanatical athlete and everything is
sports and sports and sports.
I mean,
I mean I hear his,
him and his friends talk about Tom Brady
and one of his friends like,
oh,
he's a cheater.
My son loves Tom Brady.
He's like,
oh,
he's a cheater.
I'm like,
it ain't going to be long before Max
Armstrong is at school.
And some kid in another class goes,
isn't your dad that cheater?
Like he's going to be like,
what?
Like he,
he doesn't know that,
but he,
so he's going to grow into that.
So that conversation will then be had at
that time.
It's tough to have it with a six year
old today,
but,
so I know that's coming.
Right.
And so,
but I have the experience of having
dealt with it with a 16 year old boy who
at the time was 13.
Um,
and,
and still dealing with it with those
guys.
And you know,
so far,
I mean,
I think we've been super proactive,
probably,
you know,
Anna and Kristen probably think I
should've been more proactive.
But,
um,
I think it's an,
I think that's in a good spot.
So you have group therapy sessions where
you just discuss.
So I've sat with,
with all three kids,
the older kids,
you know,
and it's just sort of free for all.
Wow.
Yeah.
And they had no idea until the scandal
broke.
Yep.
And what was their reaction?
Um,
you know,
the girls were,
they were nine,
so they were still,
they were young.
I mean,
a nine year old girl,
they really didn't have a reaction.
Luke was,
was,
uh,
a 13 year old boy.
No.
So they were 11,
so luke was 13.
They were 11.
They still sort of immune to it,
you know,
he,
he was,
I mean he watched when he watched oprah
because it airdrie or four days later I
had sort of fled to Hawaii.
I mean,
he called me up cause I talked about
luke on,
on,
on her show,
um,
with the whole idea that I know he's
defending me at school.
I mean,
there was enough smoke that people were
going,
Dude,
you're dad's a doper,
et cetera.
And he was defending me and my point,
Oprah was that at this point I get to
say to Luke,
stop defending me.
You don't need to defend me anymore.
Right.
It's true.
And so he watched that,
which is probably a heavy moment for,
for him.
It would have been awful watching it
with him.
Um,
but he called me and said,
I understand and,
and I love you.
And,
and uh,
but we still,
I mean,
that was three years ago.
We still have to talk about these
things,
man.
It it
how often?
Not,
not often.
No.
It's still occasionally comes up,
especially if you're talking about the
importance of being honest and truthful
and,
and having character.
Yeah.
And he's an athlete.
I mean,
look,
not that,
that's the only thing that I will,
and I will say,
I mean,
I don't want a ideal,
my son's huge,
six,
three,
230 pounds plays offensive line.
Like,
well,
that's good.
That is not too many people would be
fucking with him.
Yeah.
He's,
he,
I think he's good there,
but he's also a real
sweet guy.
Like he's not,
he's not a,
he's not an anybody's face.
Um,
but I don't want him to say his football
passion or,
or career,
what call it,
what you will ends up,
you know,
at a high level.
I mean,
I don't want him in a messy spot where
he's got to make tough choices.
Right.
In fact,
I don't want that at all.
And football is a sport where you have
to make tough choices.
I mean,
I'm not a football player,
but I can,
yeah.
I can imagine.
I have friends that are,
yeah.
I can imagine.
Yeah.
That's mean.
And it's also open and it's also brought
up by coaches and it's also brought up
by trainers.
I mean,
it's just a,
it's a part of the game as much as I'm
sure it is in cycling.
Yeah.
That had to be just,
it's just how to like be chewing you
apart when you know that your kids
defending you and you know it's going to
come out.
And you know,
he's having these conversations at
school and he's like,
my dad's not a cheater.
Yup.
Well,
we didn't know it was going to come out.
I mean,
even,
even when the Wicki was investigating,
I mean that,
that,
that case went away.
Right.
So we thought at that point,
maybe we're done and,
and,
and it didn't,
I mean,
you sought a picked up,
uh,
the investigation and then,
you know,
based on all his work,
they picked it up and then it came up.
But I can,
it happened fast,
like get,
it was seemingly like instantaneous man.
It be an enterprise.
You,
um,
yeah,
yeah.
I think,
I mean,
I guess it's,
yeah,
it surprised me,
but
shit,
anybody would have been surprised I
suppose.
And it was just surreal,
you know,
the way,
uh,
it,
it all came out and uh,
and,
and in the method at which they sort of
advertised the findings,
you know,
it was,
and there was a whole strip,
but to their credit,
I mean,
there was a strategy on their end.
So let's,
let's take Novitsky keys work,
let's do some additional investigations,
let's package it and what's something
they called the reason decision and then
let's go out and talk about it all over
the place like that,
that,
that was kind of unbelievable to me.
Why do you think they spent so much time
and resources going after you,
uh,
as opposed to all the other people who
have one b?
Well,
because they needed a landmark case that
I think there's plenty of people that,
that
I'm just guessing I'm not,
this is not based on any proof.
And,
and I've had conversations with,
you saw it.
I mean,
I think we're still getting to the point
where we can do stuff together or have a
conversation.
So I'm not trying to criticize them.
I mean,
I think there,
there,
there ought to be a place for them,
but I think there's also realistic.
I mean in reality there are,
there are people that think they're
ineffective.
They think they spend 10 or 20 or 50
minute,
whatever the number is,
millions of dollars a year.
And they don't catch anybody.
Right?
I mean if you look at the amount of
positives is,
must be less than 1%.
Well,
if I told you,
well Joe,
we're all good man is less than 1%
testing positive,
he would,
you would right.
You think that right?
Yeah.
So they needed,
they needed a landmark case to say,
no,
we are effective.
And here it is.
Um,
and I think also from a legal
perspective at set some legal precedents
for them that they can use going forward
in other cases with future future cases.
But,
uh,
and then you add in a,
just a ginormous story that was
guaranteed to get a lot of press.
But it still pains me to,
to,
to look,
I know what went on.
We all know what went on,
but I can't take,
uh,
when,
when I hear that,
that this program or this particular
athlete being me was the greatest fraud
in the history of sport.
You know,
I can't,
that's just not true.
Right.
And then when you hear that,
are the,
the,
our teams doping program was the most
sophisticated program in the history of
sport.
Well,
we also know that's not true.
Right?
Um,
so those are,
and then,
and then the final one was,
which is really,
I think bothered a lot of people that,
that this person being me forced young,
impressionable young men to put
dangerous substances into their body.
Right?
That just is not true.
And,
uh,
but if I heard somebody,
if somebody said that about one of my
son's friends,
I would be pissed off too.
Like I'd be like,
dude,
screw that guy.
Right?
But we all made our own choices.
We were all grown men.
They were bad choices,
right?
So most would say we would say,
um,
but,
but there was no forcing to do that.
What is it like now?
Like in a,
I mean I want you to personal,
but your personal life,
like people value honesty.
It's one of the most important things in
friends and lovers when you have this
thing where you're on video over and
over and over and over and over and over
again,
being deceptive over and over again,
defending when you,
it's,
and then you come out and say it's all a
lot.
And so there's this like database of
lying,
like what is it like,
like trying to get people to trust you,
right?
Hey man,
that's [inaudible] this is what,
this is what I talked about in the
beginning is that that that road is,
uh,
is,
is net that will be,
that is a never ending path.
I will be walking that walk the rest of
my life and there were a lot of people
that'll say,
[inaudible],
I'm never trusting this guy ever again.
I don't care.
I don't care how apologetic or tried he
is,
I'm done.
Um,
but that's,
that's the,
the key is that I have to be committed
to that path.
Right.
And so I can walk that walk and,
uh,
and,
and take each case individually and one
on one.
Um,
but
talk about in drumming,
we've talked about endurance that will
be the longest,
the longest walk or the longest journey
of my life.
Do you have a code that you follow now?
I mean,
have you imposed like,
uh,
a stringent set of rules on yourself
where like,
you know,
like,
because of this history,
you can't lie about anything ever?
No,
I mean,
I haven't thought,
I guess the answer's no because I
haven't,
there's not been a,
you know,
sort of a new mission statement or sort
of these key,
but,
but I mean
life was pretty transparent anyways
before that.
But I mean,
there was obviously there was the huge
deception.
Um,
but it's not as if,
you know,
anything crazy out there outside of
that.
Yeah.
But I mean,
you know,
um,
it's just,
that's a big thing with people to be
able to trust our friends or you'll be
able to trust their boyfriend or
girlfriend,
you know?
Yup.
For sure.
What is life like for Lance Armstrong
now?
Like is a,
is everything calmed down to the point
where the stress has minimized except
for the lawsuit?
Uh,
yeah,
it's,
as I said a sec a second ago,
it's just simple,
man.
I,
I mean,
I still,
I love to workout,
so I train every day.
I think that's what he'd do.
I,
uh,
I primarily run and then I'll do a
little bit of gym work and then,
uh,
I'll ride occasionally,
although very rarely,
very rarely get on a bike.
Um,
and
I just,
it takes too much time and it's just,
I take so much time.
I mean,
you could run for an hour.
Oh,
I said,
if you do a hard run for an hour,
you got to go ride for three hours.
So that's two more hours that you,
unless you got to get all this shit on
and go out and deal with traffic.
And it does it psychologically fuck with
you when you get on a bike.
It's,
it's,
I mean,
I have some bitterness there towards
what we've talked about primarily in and
around the economy of it,
how it was.
And now everybody's,
no,
nope.
We're out or we don't want,
right.
We're going to,
you know,
so that's,
that's,
but that's,
that's on me.
I got to work that out.
And that's not,
that's not their fault.
That's my fault.
So there's some of that and it's nice to
do.
I love to run on me.
I grew up,
I ran before I wrote,
so it's,
it's nice to go into something where I
can still get,
I mean,
I view working out,
you probably view it the same way.
It's almost like a therapy.
Like you're in there,
you're suffering,
you're just working shit out.
Right.
And that's what,
that's what I do when I,
um,
when I work out or go for a long run.
So I do that,
uh,
a joke.
I mean we have,
you know,
I have five kids are in four different
schools,
so it's um,
like an uber driver for my kids.
But traffic in Austin is not like la,
but it's bad.
Now.
This again bad now and so all I do is
drive my kids around.
Too many people talk about how Great
Austin is.
That's what happened.
Right?
Well the,
but they didn't build that city 50 years
ago to accommodate 2 million people.
And then,
uh,
I played a lot.
I play a lot of golf,
which is why we're going to end this
podcast will,
that's why I can go play Riviera.
They man,
don't mess up my tee time.
I don't,
I don't want to mess with you tea time.
I appreciate your time very much.
But we've already done,
we can keep going.
Keep going.
I Dunno if Higgs is here yet.
He's,
I'm sure he's here.
Someone's calling me.
That's on him.
Um,
and then you got the hunter book.
We got to talk a little bit about
hunter.
Yeah,
definitely.
I didn't know you were a fan until I saw
your,
maybe bill burr retweeted.
Maybe you're a tweet that said,
if anybody,
if there's one person that's dead that,
that,
you know,
that I could meet today or was alive
would be hunter.
Yeah.
It was a instagram post that I made
about one of his incredible quotes
about,
um,
it was about heroes and it was,
uh,
it was particularly poignant about a,
it was after Ronda Rousey got knocked
out,
but I posted it that people,
they,
they love the idea of someone who is
like a superhuman person,
like someone who's a legend,
someone who,
who can defy the odds because it gives
them hope in this crazy world,
boredom and cubicles.
And I'm doing a shitty job of
paraphrasing it,
but it's a fantastic quote.
And then you got a hold of me about it.
And,
uh,
had that incredible book sent to me.
What an a hunter was running for sheriff
of Aspen.
Yup.
So he,
yeah,
he,
he just,
you know,
he kind of ruled the valley.
I mean,
he lived down in Woody Creek,
but,
but the whole,
um,
the whole valley was the roaring fork
valley was kind of his domain and he was
just in,
his best friend was,
was our longtime sheriff.
He was the sheriff for 26 years.
Bob Brown,
who's a great friend of mine,
uh,
his under sheriff is probably my best
bud there,
a guy named by the name of Joe de Salvo.
So how a kid from Brooklyn ends up in
Aspen is now the sheriff is on a second
term.
So Joey and Bob were,
were hunters best buddies.
I mean,
fucking crazy stories and I,
and,
and not to toot my own horn,
but in bob has,
is the sweetest.
He was,
he's the guy that was shared for 26
years.
He says to me one day,
he says,
he calls me champ,
which is also funny.
He says,
Jampie says,
uh,
did you ever meet hunter?
And I said,
no,
I never met him.
And he pauses for a long time.
And he goes,
man,
he would have loved you.
I was,
I took that.
I was like,
fucking,
hey,
that was a compliment right there.
Hunter was,
was,
was nuts and,
and a lot of ways,
but I know,
I mean,
he had such a diverse group of friends,
whether it's,
whether it was our sheriff or whether it
was lyle lovett or whether it was Johnny
Depp or whether it was Doug Brinkley.
I mean,
just,
just this diverse group of fucking
artists and thinkers and lawmen and,
and druggies and dude,
gnarly.
I mean,
he'd go out to the shit they did was
just,
I probably can't even talk about it.
I'm sure you can.
He's dead.
It's fine.
There were some of the people are still
alive,
still alive when we were talking before
the podcast about his ritual,
uh,
before you would,
right.
So like,
yeah,
superhuman.
So I you,
so you read that and if for those
listening or you just google,
you know,
a hunter Thompson's daily regime and
you'll,
it'll come up,
I think esquire wrote it and the shit
starts at like,
what is,
he wakes up at like three in the
afternoon,
right?
And it just,
you got to go read it.
I mean it's,
it's unbelievable.
So I thought,
this is so unreal.
It ain't true.
So I called Joey,
our sheriff and I said,
dude,
I have you seen this?
And he says,
yeah,
I said that,
that's not real.
You know what he said?
He said,
that isn't enough.
that's light.
Can you believe,
go read it people and then imagine that,
that,
that didn't quite get there.
Well Jamie,
why don't you find it?
Cause it's,
it's kind of hilarious.
We could actually read it on the air
dude.
Yeah.
He,
um,
he had a strong tolerance for substances
and he,
I don't think he ever went without,
I mean it's just he wasn't interested.
No,
no.
Yeah.
I mean that was,
that was the life that he was interested
in.
He was interested in just getting fucked
up and having a great time and,
and writing about shit and pontificating
on the demise of civilization.
Yeah.
But it,
but you know,
I don't know if that's what caught up to
him,
but it definitely did.
I mean,
how could you,
did you ever see the late appearances?
I,
I have a really hard time watching his
later appearances.
Like we would do like the Conan O'brien
show and you could understand a word he
was saying.
Like here,
you can see it right here.
3:00 PM rise through.
Feel five chivas regal with morning
papers,
done hills,
three 45 cocaine,
three 50,
another glass of Chevys and other
dunhill.
Uh,
four or five,
four first cup of coffee in her mind
her,
this is pm
four 15 cocaine for 16 orange juice.
Dunhill for 30 cocaine for 54 cocaine,
five oh five cocaine,
five 11 coffee done hills,
five 30 more ice in the shivers,
five 45 cocaine,
etc. Etc.
6:00 PM grass to take the edge the day,
three hours he's been awake if it's
stressful.
Seven o' clock,
woody creek tavern for lunch with
Heineken to Margarita is coast law,
a Taco Salad,
double order,
fried onion rings,
carrot cake,
ice cream,
a bean fritter,
done hills and other Heineken cocaine.
And for the ride home,
a snow cone,
a class of shredded ice over which has
poured a three or four jiggers of a
Chevys,
God dammit,
nine start snorting cocaine.
Seriously.
Now it got serious,
10 drops,
acid,
11 chartreuse,
cocaine,
grass,
1130 cocaine,
etc. Etc.
Midnight Hunter s Thompson is ready to
write that is,
and then it keeps going on.
1205 to 6:00 AM chartreuse.
Cocaine grass.
Shiv is coffee,
Heineken,
clove,
cigarettes,
grapefruit done hills,
orange juice,
gin,
continuous pornographic movies.
Six in the hot tub.
Champagne,
dove bars,
fettuccine Alfredo Alfredo.
8:00 AM Halsey on is that,
I say it a sleeping pills.
The first.
That was before I.
Ambien.
Yeah.
Eight 20 sleep.
Wow.
Jesus Christ.
So I asked the guys,
I asked the sheriff's,
I'm like,
that kid shit's not real.
Yeah.
There's the,
uh,
the quote that I po myths and legends
die hard in America.
We Love them for the extra dimension.
They provide the illusion of near
infinite possibility to erase the narrow
confines of most men's reality.
Weird heroes and mold breaking champions
exist as proof to those who needed that.
The tyranny of the rat race is not yet
final.
Yeah.
I mean,
this isn't like that.
that applies to you to do that.
I understand that it applies to your
life.
Yeah.
I mean,
and that's part of the reason I'm sure
why some people were pissed at you.
It's like you were a legend with a
caveat.
Yup.
Yeah.
I mean the,
the,
the story in its totality,
right?
If I was just a cyclist,
we wouldn't be having this conversation.
But,
but the cancer part of the story,
right,
is what everybody really,
nobody,
nobody could relate to cycling and they
got to figure it out.
They started to watch it.
That cool.
You want,
again,
the cancer part of it,
everybody can relate to.
Right.
I mean,
every,
everybody is either had the disease
themselves or lost a loved one or had a
loved one or friend or neighbor affected
by it.
So they're like,
all right,
I'm in like,
that is some bullshit right there that
dizzy.
And they rallied around that.
And that's,
you know,
that's,
that's why that fall came swift and
harsh.
Well,
there's parallels in life when it comes
to this story and a lot of ways because
everything is kind of messy,
you know,
the,
the reality versus the narrative,
it's always messy.
Yeah.
And there's so many variables that don't
get discussed,
and there's so many aspects of it that
they're flexible and they move around
and,
and that's,
yeah.
I mean,
more and more now,
the transparency we see in our society
today,
whether it's politicians or politics or
sports or entertainment and just,
I mean,
do,
do you imagine,
like,
I always say like,
you know,
if,
if I give you three names that were
alive today,
like Sinatra,
we just,
you know,
just had celebrated his hundredth
birthday [inaudible] you took Sinatra,
JFK,
and Michael Jordan,
and they,
and they were at their peak today.
TMZ alone would be nuking people.
Yeah.
And so,
uh,
it just,
it's,
we're just getting deeper and deeper
into that.
Yeah.
It's,
and I think this is just,
there's no end to the beginning.
Yeah.
Oh,
for sure.
Well,
I think what's going on with technology
too is we're seeing this very obvious
trend that the boundaries between people
and thoughts and ideas and reality and
facts.
Yep.
They're getting smaller and smaller and
smaller to the point where they're going
to be erased.
And I don't know how it's going to
happen,
but I think it's going to happen with
something that connects us and in a much
more personal way than peripheral
devices like laptops or phones.
I think there's gonna be some technology
that connects us body to body,
whether it's some sort of a neural
implant or something along those lines.
Yeah.
I really do.
I think it's on inevitable.
Yeah.
I mean,
the symbiotic relationship that we have
with cell phones right now is
undeniable.
I leave my fault.
Like you,
you dropped your phone and you're like,
fuck,
where's my phone?
My phone's broken.
Fuck,
fuck.
Fuck
no here.
Yeah.
I mean,
I dropped it,
so I did drop my phone,
but I'm like,
I'm like fucking scratching myself
because I haven't had the phone for like
two or three hours.
Yeah,
dude,
it's,
that ain't good.
No,
it's not good.
I leave my phone sometimes in the,
in the car when I go do the podcast and
I don't realize that I left it and I'll
be in the middle of a great podcast.
Like my phone's not here.
I'm not even gonna use it.
It's out there.
I don't touch it.
But the fact that it's not physically
like I want it right there.
You know you're on here and you just
start like,
you know you've got some guests on,
you're like texting him and the guests
will be like,
what the fuck?
What's he do?
Yeah,
I come all the way over here.
This godforsaken valley and that la
traffic
and the guy's on his phone.
Yeah.
Well I have had people that are guests
that start checking their twitter.
Like Neal Brennan would try and start
checking his twitter in the middle of
pocket.
What the fuck are you doing?
I want to see what people are saying
about it.
Talk to them afterwards.
Just flip your people.
You don't let people call in and ask
questions or ask questions.
We've done that before.
But the problem is that people that want
to do it are usually trolls.
You know,
some of those might be fun.
I like if I wanted that kind of a show,
I would do an all call.
And she did a talk,
I did a talk a couple of couple months
ago
in Denver and the 600 people and it was
kind of a moderated q and a and then we,
and then the audience was allowed to ask
questions and people were cool.
They were asking questions in the
moderator says in,
there's a line to get to the mic desk
questions and the guy says,
ah,
not that this light,
I'm not connecting,
you know,
calling her a troll.
But the guy says,
is anybody in really
pissed at Lance?
And one ask a question,
this lady in the back,
she's like me,
she comes trucking up there.
And so,
you know,
I was like,
this is going to be super interesting.
Like what the hell is she going to ask
me?
How am I going to answer it?
So I,
I,
you know,
maybe I like a challenge,
but you definitely like a challenge.
I think you're just bored.
And between Golf Games you want to spar
with somebody verbally ask kids if my
phone got fixed.
Did he text you?
He's probably out there.
I looked when I went to them and so the
bathroom is a hawk.
Cool.
Thanks.
That's the last thing he said here.
I'll text him right now.
You are out there who says hot,
cool things he did because he said,
can,
I said you wanted it advil.
He says,
I said,
lance would like you to bring advil.
He says,
hoc.
Cool,
thanks.
And I said,
uh,
yeah,
it was his birthday last night.
We went out to dinner and just we got w
way too drunk.
It happens.
Um,
what we were talking about about
technology though about uh,
bringing people closer together in this,
the fact that there's going to,
I mean,
I really think there's going to be no
secrets.
I don't think anybody's going to have
secrets from anybody in the future.
Right.
I think,
um,
you kind of,
you caught like the wave of this trend
before it got even crazier than it.
I mean,
you caught that wave and even in 2012
the comparison between 2012 and 2015
it's like it's ramped up.
Consider it for sure and will continue
to do that yet.
Yeah.
There's no getting around it,
right?
Yeah.
Is that good?
Is that a good thing
or is it just what it is?
Yeah.
You and I are not going to stop it so
that it's inevitable.
No one is nobody's.
I think it's going to not just,
Oh,
it's just,
it's one of the things it's going to
happen is it's not going to just be
celebrities.
It's not going to be just people like
you.
People like Michael Jordan or whoever.
It's going to be everybody.
Right.
It's going to be,
if you want to find out anything about
Jamie,
it's going to be all on the table.
Maybe Jamie was one of those Ashley
Madison Clients.
He could have been the odd Wicki was ah,
well there had been some fucking
ridiculous people that were that one up
killing themselves when like preachers
and shit like that,
that it was found out.
But how dumb do you have to be to think
that that's going to be secure?
You're going to go on some dating site.
I mean,
come on man.
I'm like,
Ooh,
that's,
that's insane.
But you know what kind of a fucking
Weirdo wants to find out about people
that were on the dating site?
Like,
well,
what do you give a shit?
Leave me alone.
Exactly.
But that's not the world we live in.
Right.
I gotta take a leak again.
You do you well,
it's what's in this fucking thing.
What's in it?
Yeah,
we're good.
We're done.
I think 1130 it's 11 supposed to tee off
at 1130 but all right,
where are you?
Really?
Yeah,
but I'll find it.
I'm going to meet him out there.
It's all okay.
It's all good man.
Thank you lance.
Really appreciate.
Thank you.
Thanks for doing that.
And thanks for listening,
whoever.
Hopefully somebody lists.
A lot of people are so cool.
I'm sure that's it.
Bye everybody.
Bye.
Okay.